the world is big place so if I very
modestly can you know narrow down to the
Netherlands which is very small not very
important a country and in terms of the
Nexus Institute one of the things we
discovered is that there are a lot of
things in involved media and cultural
and education a lot of things are going
wrong on the side of the suppliers I
don't want to insult anybody but you
know politics produces media moguls and
so on and so forth for whatever reason
they think that people are stupid or
they consider themselves as not
interested in certain things and because
they are not interested in it they think
that people are not interested in so why
should we provide them with should be
easy should be accessible as well as the
4th and with a lie we think this is a
form of democracy it has nothing to do
whatsoever with democracy it's a stupid
form of marketing my experience is that
a growing group of people everywhere
also here in America is hungry for
quality but in such a way that they
don't have the feeling that somebody is
completely intrusive and and tells them
with a certain Authority you have to
think this or you must do that or
whatever so I wanted to create a former
a we can raise the quintessential
questions everybody is confronted with
be get the opposites together around the
table or at least a rich variety of
people and so one of the things we say
is look we are there to make a life a
little bit more difficult because at the
end of the day you will not have any
answers but you will realise probably
better what the premises are what the
consequences are and that there are no
easy answers to big problems or two big
question
out of great already the awareness I
think it's an important thing and the
Institute in the Netherlands is a huge
success now a little bit more on my or
on the live level of me as an individual
the book I've been writing a working on
and I hope that my contribution is that
I can be helpful in giving back to
meaning to certain words because that's
that's so important one of the big
influences of mass media and mass
society is that as we just discussed you
know words have lost their meaning like
love like friendship and there is an
enormous form of reductionism going on
and and it is which is a terrifying
phenomenon a lot of the and what we have
had anti-semitism and many ways where is
still a lot of anti-semitism in Europe
and in other places in Europe we are now
also dealing with the phenomenon of
anti-americanism according to the latest
polls and also anti-americanism is
simply based on the fact that you are
dealing with an enormous reduction of
you know complex reality and this form
of reductionism makes it's one-sided
narrow-minded and we don't longer have
the capacity of understand what the idea
of America is all about now this is the
same for all kinds of other words
you